so far Democrats seem to have learned
nothing from their futile battle against
Brett Cavanaugh's confirmation they put
the country through three weeks of what
basically amounted to a he-said she-said
I thought that Brett was accidentally
going to kill me I've never done this to
her or to anyone they youth paid
activists to corner senators they helped
still protests that range from unhinged
to downright pathetic I'm not paying
attention
limits are sorely learn some rhymes
every now and then all right well they
use their pals in the press to run with
the most outlandish unsubstantiated
claims possible the nomination of Judge
Brett Kavanaugh plunges deeper into
danger tonight over an allegation of
sexual assault that leaves his
confirmation in mortal jeopardy third
allegation of sexual misconduct against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
surfaced today what we know about the
allegations from the third accuser and
the late-breaking news of a fourth
accuser she considers her own memories
credible and she felt it was important
that she tell her story before others
did without her consent but despite all
their efforts the emotional pleas and
all the big money behind their smears on
Saturday afternoon Cavanaugh was
confirmed by the US Senate so after
their spectacular flame out one of the
Democrats do in response they double
down on failure if he is on the Supreme
Court and and the Senate hasn't
investigated
in the house we'll have to you'll
investigate we would have to investigate
any credible allegations I'm totally
focused with all the angry women and the
men who listened to women and support
the credible accounts of sexual
harassment and sexual assault which is
very underreported that I'm focused like
a laser beam on the elections but there
are signs that this angry gender
politics game is just not working
a marriage poll last week found that
there's virtually no gender gap when it
comes to justice Brett Kavanaugh among
either Republicans or Democrats eighty
percent of Republican women have a
favorable view of Kavanagh
with 81% of Republican men agreeing and
on the Democratic side men have a
greater unfavorable view of Kavanagh 85%
to 75% of women well
the struggle over Kavanagh as we noted
in the angle shortly after he was
nominated was always going to be
political the Democrats were gonna
savage anyone Donald Trump nominated
except maybe if he read AMA nated
someone like a Merrick garland there's
something completely cuckoo like that
the perpetual rage against all things
Trump also seems to intensify the more
Trump accomplishes and it's unrelated by
the way to how optimistic and how
confident American workers and consumers
are about the economy none of that even
matters to the crazies on the Left
consider what the president with the
help of Mitch McConnell has accomplished
just on this very important issue of
judicial nominations of course two
Supreme Court justices twenty-six
federal appellate court judges and 41
federal district court judges and by the
way they're just getting started and of
course President Trump has chalked up so
many other impressive wins gets very
little credit in the mainstream media
for it he's successfully renegotiated
NAFTA forcing both Mexico and Canada to
accept a deal that finally begins to
treat American manufacturers and
American workers fairly
he's rolled back needless government
regulations by the way for every new
regulation the Trump federal agency
issued they've basically rescinded 22
the government estimates that the
lifetime net cost savings of his D
regulatory efforts is about 8.1 billion
dollars and Trump passed the largest tax
cut in a generation manufacturing jobs
are back the GDP is about 4 percent and
we have the lowest unemployment in
nearly 50 years Trump is taking on China
for their years of cheating and stealing
from the American workers and American
businesses and finally we have an
administration that recognizes the
threat that this expansive communist
regime poses to our own national and
economic security
[Applause]
Trump is transforming both the country
in the Republican Party and not a moment
too soon
even the ranks of some of the never
Trump furs have dwindled and they
grudgingly admit the genius and success
of Donald Trump
the Cavanagh struggle was a clarifying
moment for the never Trump crowd like a
political astringent Brett Stevens Hugh
Hewitt and Erick Erickson all wind up
behind the president in the midst of the
Cavanaugh fight some more than others
but nevertheless it's a big change by
the way remember this was Eric Erickson
who's head of that red state website
back in August of 2015 I wanted to give
the man a lot of latitude because I know
he taps into some anger that even I
share with the Republican Party and a
lot of us here do but if our standard
bearer has to resort to that we need a
new standard bearer and this is eric
erickson to the Washington Examiner last
week quote for the first time I see
myself voting for Trump in 2020 it has a
lot to do with Kavanagh he's not the
only reason but he's definitely the
straw that broke the camel's back is
Eric calling himself a camel or is that
the left anyway I'm happy and I'm glad
Eric's a good guy of course
establishment figures such as Mitch
McConnell and Lindsey Graham John Cornyn
neither none of those guys who wanted
Trump to be the nominee they have all
really stepped up to help push Cavanaugh
over the confirmation finish line maybe
maybe they're closer all of them to
recognizing that times up on the old GOP
and Trump's policies are actually
bearing fruit all the excitement is with
Trump let's face it all the momentum is
with his ideas there's too much on the
line for intra-party squabbles any
longer and the choice for voters is now
really simple mob rule or the rule of
law perpetual rage or real results
demonization or due process
as an example this is what the
anti-trump rage machine was up to over
the weekend protesters in Portland
blocked a major thoroughfare causing
needless disruption when a driver dared
to push through the blockade this was
the reaction of these open-minded and
tolerant leftists like a scene from
homeland or something from Benghazi the
far left let's face it is now running
the Democratic asylum the main base of
the Democrats have shifted so far left
that will end up being Venezuela this
country would end up being Venezuela I
think a lot of Democrats are going to be
voting Republican ticket tonight I felt
very privileged to be in attendance as
former Justice Anthony Kennedy swore in
our new justice in the Supreme Court my
friend of many many years and one of
America's finest legal minds Brett
Kavanaugh as a suit of Justice of the
Supreme Court of the United States as
Associate Justice of the Supreme Court
the Constitution man you could feel the
excitement in that room and it was it
was a lot of amazing most amazing
political moments I've been a privileged
to observe I mean while the haters on
the left are swearing retribution in
promising more mayhem so I say when they
go low we hit harder
[Applause]
[Applause]
therefore women right women can be
anything they want to be or think
whatever they want to think don't
believe that for a second
my friends the choice is yours coming up
really soon it's election day and that's
the angle